The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Are people
understanding AVLs?
That's good, because if
everyone raised their hands,
we'd be done and out of here.
So we're not covering new
material in this recitation.
We're talking about AVLs
again, except this time
you'll tell me
how we'll do them,
and we'll look at
the code and see
how the theory matches the code.
And I need one of these.
Thank you.
So let's start simple.
What's a BST?
AUDIENCE: Binary search tree.
PROFESSOR: OK,
binary search tree.
It's binary because every
node has at most two children.
Why is it a search tree?
AUDIENCE: It's easy to search.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Why is it easy to search?
AUDIENCE: Because you
start [INAUDIBLE],
is my number greater than
this key or is it less than,
and then you go from there.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So if I would have to state
this as a formal rep invariant
thing, what would I say it is
so that I can do that operation?
AUDIENCE: Node at
right is greater than
node at key, which is
greater than node at left.
PROFESSOR: OK, excellent.
So it turns out I can use
this argument recursively
to say that for a given
node, everything that
is to the right of
that node is greater,
and everything that is
to the left is smaller.
And this allows us
to do search quickly
because if you're
looking for a key,
say you have numbers in your
tree and you're looking for 5.
If you arrive at a node whose
value is 4, you go right.
value is 7, you go left.
OK So what do we know
how to do on BSTs?
What are the operations
that we know?
AUDIENCE: Minimum, maximum.
PROFESSOR: Min, max.
AUDIENCE: Left, right, parent.
PROFESSOR: So those
are for the node.
I want the queries and the
updates for the BST type.
AUDIENCE: Insert and delete.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Insert, Delete.
AUDIENCE: Next larger.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And then in here, the S in BST.
Someone give me the
S so we can move on.
AUDIENCE: Find.
PROFESSOR: Find,
search, depending
on what code you're reading.
What's the running
time for these guys?
AUDIENCE: Order h.
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
So everything has the
same running time.
Nice and easy to remember.
Order h.
What's h?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
How do we define this height?
What's the height for this tree?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Good.
What's the height for this tree?
AUDIENCE: Two.
PROFESSOR: So now for
a more general case,
where this is the height, and
the height of my left subtree
is hl.
The height of my
right subtree is hr.
What's h?
AUDIENCE: It's the maximum
of hr times hl plus 1.
PROFESSOR: Nice save.
I heard a "plus 1"
somewhere there.
Very good.
This is r.
So if we look at the
first part of the code,
lines one through eight,
lines seven and eight
implement the definition
that we talked about here.
So in our Python
implementation, each node
knows the height of the
tree that he's the root of.
And since we're
storing that, we need
to update it every once in
awhile when we make changes
to the tree, like
when we insert nodes.
And the way we do that
is update height, which
uses the formula that
we came up with here.
Now, there is a hack on
lines two, three, four, five.
Can anyone tell me
what the hack is?
AUDIENCE: The negative 1.
PROFESSOR: OK.
How does that work?
Why do I need it?
AUDIENCE: That's so if
you're at the root node,
you can still
calculate the height.
PROFESSOR: Depends on how
the root node looks like.
AUDIENCE: If it has no children.
PROFESSOR: That's a leaf.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So if I'm in this case or
in this case, what's hl,
what's hr?
In this case, I have
this node of height zero,
so I can make a small mistake
here and it'll save me,
but here, I have no
children, so hl and hr have
to be set in such a way that
this formula evaluates to 0.
If I set them to minus 1,
I'll have minus 1, minus 1.
The maximum is minus
1 plus 1 equals 0.
AUDIENCE: It's just to
check the nodes for AVLs.
PROFESSOR: We use that
to update the height.
For AVLs, we need
to know the height
of a node instantaneously.
We can't afford to
go down the tree
and compute the height
every time we need it,
so every node gets
to store its height.
There's a small field in each
node that has the height.
So we need to update that
every once in awhile when
we do insertions and deletions.
This is how we update
it, and in order
to update it for this case,
where we're at a leaf,
we have to say that the
height of a non-existing tree
is minus 1.
Of course, in theory
and in real life,
there are no non-existing
trees, so this is a clever hack
to reduce code size.
So we said binary search trees
would look something like this.
Is this guy an AVL?
Does anyone think it's an a AVL?
Does anyone think
it's not an AVL?
Can one of you tell me why?
AUDIENCE: The tree with 5
as its root is not balanced.
PROFESSOR: So this guy
here is not balanced.
Why is it not balanced?
AUDIENCE: Because it has two on
its right and zero on its left,
so the difference
is greater than 1.
PROFESSOR: You're saying
that there's something here
that's two, and something
here that's-- OK, so height.
So then it's almost like that.
It's 1 here and minus 1 here.
So the reason I
asked you to clarify
is that first you
said two and zero,
and that's the
node count, and AVL
doesn't care about node count.
AVL cares about height.
So for example, if I
have something like this,
this is a happy AVL.
Three nodes, here one node here.
The difference in node
count is greater than 1,
but the difference
in height is 1.
Therefore, this is a good AVL.
So what's a rep
invariant for an AVL?
AUDIENCE: The height of the
left subtree for every node
is within 1 of the height
of the right subtree.
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
AVL.
The core property is
that for every node,
the left height and the right
height differ by at most 1.
What else?
If we want to be
completely rigorous,
what else do we have to say?
It's a BST.
So an AVL is a
special kind of BST,
and that's why when
we write the AVL code,
we inherit from the BST and
we use some of its methods
heavily.
Why do we like AVLs?
What's so good about them?
AUDIENCE: It's faster because
it ensures the minimal height
of the entire tree because most
of our complexities are o of h,
so it would have to be smaller.
PROFESSOR: So we
care about this.
In a regular binary tree,
the worst case that you have
is this.
Ignoring this part, this is a
worst case binary search tree
where it's basically a
list, so height is order n.
In an AVL, you're
saying it's better.
So the reason why we
care about AVLs is
that height is order of log n.
Now, did people understand from
lecture why that's the case?
Can anyone tell me
why that's the case?
AUDIENCE: Well, it's
just like every level
you go down, if you split off
that many times, of course
it's log n.
If you have n nodes and
they're filled up to the edge,
there's going to
be log n of them.
AUDIENCE: It's close to a
full binary tree, right?
PROFESSOR: For some
definition of "close."
So here's what I
use to remember,
and I think I can persuade you
that the height is log n using
the argument that
I'll show you here.
Let's start building
a tree this way.
Let's say I have a
fixed height, and I
want to have as few
nodes as possible.
If I have a tree with a big
height and very few nodes,
h is going to be bad when you
write it as a function of n.
So those trees are unbalanced.
Big height, small
number of nodes.
So say we're trying to build
an AVL with the smallest
number of nodes
and a fixed height.
What if the height is 0?
What does that tree look like?
It's not too complicated, right?
This is an AVL of height 0.
It's the only possible
AVL of height 0.
Now, what if we're trying
to build an AVL of height 1
that has as few
nodes as possible?
This is what it
looks like, right?
Height 0, height 1.
I could add another
node here, but I
don't want to because I want
as few nodes as possible.
Now, what if I tried to
build an AVL of height 2
that has as few
nodes as possible?
Can I do this?
AUDIENCE: So at the worst
case, you have h minus 1
and then h minus 2 there.
PROFESSOR: OK.
You're moving ahead.
You're forcing me to move
faster, but you're right.
And the reason is
this is unbalanced.
The height at the left has
to be the height of the right
plus or minus 1.
Can't be anything else.
So at the very least, I have to
build a tree of height 0 here,
and I know that the
best tree of height
0 that I have is this guy.
Cool.
So for height 3, I
would have to do this.
And then you're saying, what
would I use at the left?
AUDIENCE: You'd use whatever
height's on the right minus 2.
The height on the
right minus 1 per side.
PROFESSOR: So on the
right, I have a height 2.
On the left, I have a height 1.
If I want to go up to height
4, I do the same thing.
So if I want to
build an AVL tree
with as few nodes as
possible and height h,
I start with the root,
then at the right,
I build an AVL tree of height
h minus 1, and at the left,
an AVL tree of height h minus 2.
And if these have the
minimum number of nodes,
then it turns out
that the whole thing
has the minimum number of nodes.
I don't want to build a
tree where the heights are
equal because that would
mean more nodes here,
so this is the best I can do.
This is the best way I
can build a tall tree
with as few nodes as possible.
Suppose I want to write
the number of nodes
as a function of height.
You're telling me what it is.
When I was here, you were
giving me the answer for this.
So suppose I have
a height, and I
want to know how many nodes
I have in my tree that
has a minimum number of nodes.
What is it?
AUDIENCE: It's N h minus 1,
and then plus N h minus 2.
There might be a constant.
PROFESSOR: There
might be a constant.
N h minus 1 is this tree,
N h minus 2 is this tree,
so what's the constant?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yep.
This guy.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't he
have height 0, though?
AUDIENCE: We're talking
number of nodes.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
Number of nodes, yeah.
PROFESSOR: I'm not
going to solve this now.
We learned how to solve
recurrences a long time ago,
so I'll pretend I still
remember how to do that,
and I will tell you
that the solution looks
something like this.
N of h is roughly 5, which is
the magic number that we talked
about in lecture--
roughly, which
means there might be some things
there that I forgot-- to the h.
What really matters is that
it's an exponential in h.
If you look at these guys,
this is close to the Fibonacci
number formula except
there's a plus 1 here.
So these guys are bigger
than the Fibonacci numbers.
This is definitely
bigger than whatever
the formula for
Fibonacci numbers
is, which is 5 to the h minus
something over something.
What really matters is the
minimum number of nodes
in an AVL of height h is an
exponential as a function of h.
If you invert that, you
get that the maximum height
for a tree with N nodes
is log N. This is a way
to construct an AVL that
shows you that the height has
to be logarithmic as long
as we can keep this rep
invariant true.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
I didn't quite follow how you
got h minus 2 and h minus 1
there.
PROFESSOR: Here, here, here?
AUDIENCE: There.
The tree down.
This one?
AUDIENCE: This one, yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So suppose I'm at height 4 here.
What's the best way to
construct an AVL that
has as few nodes as
possible but height 4?
If this guy has
to be at height 4,
then it has to have a child at
height 3, at least one child.
Otherwise, it's not
going to be height 4.
Now, I need to build something
here that has height 3.
What should I build?
The best AVL tree that I know
that has height 3, right?
I have to get to height 3
using as few nodes as possible,
so I'm going to use this guy
because it has as few nodes as
possible and it has height 3.
So this covers my right side.
Now, for my left side, what
am I going to use here?
Another AVL tree that has as
few nodes as possible, right?
So I'm definitely keeping that.
But what's going to
be the height of that?
AUDIENCE: So we want the
difference to be less than
or equal to 1?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Otherwise, it's not an AVL.
AUDIENCE: So it
would be of height 4.
PROFESSOR: So I know for sure
that this guy has height 4.
The difference has
to be plus, minus 1.
AUDIENCE: So it would be 2.
PROFESSOR: 2, 3, 4.
I know for sure I
don't want it to be 4,
and now I have to
choose between 2 and 3.
A tree of height 2
will have fewer nodes
than a tree of
height 3, so that's
why we're doing it this way.
So to build a tree of height
4, build a tree of height 3,
build a tree of height
2, connect them together.
That's how we get to
this, and then this.
Cool.
Do people remember how to
do insertions and deletions
in a regular binary tree?
Yes?
How do I insert 6.5
here in this one?
AUDIENCE: You take 6.5, you're
like, oh, it's greater than 4,
then you move to 5.
Then you're like, oh,
it's greater than 5.
Go to 6.
Oh, it's less than 6, and
then it goes to the left of 6.
I mean-- sorry.
I meant left of 7.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So it's bigger than--
AUDIENCE: Testing you all, guys.
Oh yeah.
6.5 is bigger than 6, so
then it goes to the left of 7
because it's less than 7.
PROFESSOR: I thought I had my
example wrong for a second.
AUDIENCE: I'm just tired.
PROFESSOR: Me too,
so don't scare me.
All right.
So suppose we have heights
stored in the nodes here,
because we want to
do that for AVLs.
We'll figure out why in a bit.
The height of this guy used
to be 0, 1, 2, 3, right?
0, 1, 2, 3.
What happened when
I added this node?
AUDIENCE: You added 1 to
everything [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I went down on
my insertion path
to find out where to insert
a node, and then I added it.
I just chose my
case conveniently,
but in some cases,
all the heights
of the nodes on that
path have changed.
So in an AVL,
after we insert, we
have to make sure
that the height
of every node on
the path is updated.
Does this make sense?
So the heights
will be 1, 2, 3, 4.
So the way we
implemented the AVLs is
that we do regular
insertions and deletions,
and then at the end, we say,
well it used to be an AVL.
Now we added or
removed the node,
so it might be a
slightly unbalanced AVL,
which means it's not an AVL.
And we have the
rebalance procedure.
So if you look at on the
second page of the code,
insert and delete are
really tiny, lines 20 to 22
and 24 to 28.
And they're really tiny
because they call the old code
and then they call Rebalance.
So all the magic in an
AVL is in Rebalance.
The first thing that
Rebalance does, if you see,
it has a while loop there, and
the first thing that it does
in the while loop is it updates
the height, and this is why.
The height might have
changed after the insert,
so any decision based on
the old height is bad.
That's why we have that there.
Make sense so far?
So if you look at rebalance,
don't try to understand it
quite yet, but
what it does is it
calls Rotate Left
and Rotate Right.
Well, Left Rotate, Right Rotate.
All the magic is in Rebalance,
and the tools that it uses
are Left Rotate
and Right Rotate.
Now, I'm going to show you
what a rotation is supposed
to do in-- and the children
of these nodes are a, b, c, d.
Also, this node is hanging
off of something here, e.
If I want to do a
Right Rotate here,
so if I want to rotate the tree
like this, then after rotating,
it's going to look like this.
So notice that c got moved
from B to A, but it got
moved in such a way that the
whole thing is still a BST.
These guys show up in the
same order as children,
and these guys show
up in the same order,
so search will still work.
This is how it's supposed
to look like as a picture.
Let's try to write the
pseudocode for achieving this.
AUDIENCE: First, you
identify the parent node.
Step one.
PROFESSOR: Well,
let's say we have it.
AUDIENCE: I mean from B.
You say, A is my parent.
That's now going to
become my right child.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what do you want to change?
By the way, this whole thing
has to happen in constant time,
so we're not allowed to go
anywhere inside here, here,
here, or here.
We're allowed to
change these links,
but if you go
inside and try to do
more complicated
restructuring, that's
going to block the running time.
We're only allowed
to change the links
that you see on the board.
AUDIENCE: I know in the BST, not
BST node but BST, the delete,
if you're deleting the root,
they make up the pseudoroot.
PROFESSOR: Let's
not worry about it.
So Delete already did
that magic for you, right?
So the pseudoroot would be
here, so this node has a root.
We're happy.
AUDIENCE: That's not
what I'm talking about.
I'm saying that you could do
the same with B because you're
going to have to break a
link with lowercase c onto B
in order to flip it.
So I'm saying you could have
a placer, some sort of place
to put it so you don't lose it.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's see if we do that.
AUDIENCE: The new right
child of B will be A,
and the new left child of A will
be C, and the new parent of c
is A.
PROFESSOR: OK,
let's move slower.
I have to write them down.
So the new right child of B is?
AUDIENCE: Is A.
Also, you probably
should do temp
variables to store them.
AUDIENCE: I don't
think you have to.
You can just swap the one
connection and swap the other.
PROFESSOR: Let's do it
without worrying about temps,
and then we can figure
out temps later.
So B's right becomes A. So
it's going to be like this.
Let me erase this
confusing error.
AUDIENCE: And A's
left child is c.
PROFESSOR: A's left child is c.
OK.
AUDIENCE: C's parent is A.
PROFESSOR: C's parent
is A. OK, very good.
So I changed the child,
then I changed the parent
so that they would match up.
So if B's right is A, then
what should I do with--
AUDIENCE: A's parent is B.
PROFESSOR: Always
do them in pairs
so you don't lose track of them.
And?
AUDIENCE: B's parent is
e and e's subchild is B.
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
B's parent is e, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So B's
parent is e, and--
AUDIENCE: e's left.
PROFESSOR: Child is--
AUDIENCE: B.
PROFESSOR: Because I
drew it like this, right?
But if I drew it like this?
AUDIENCE: e's--
PROFESSOR: It would have
to be the right child,
so we have to look
at both cases.
AUDIENCE: If B is
greater than e,
then it would be right child,
and if B is less than e,
it would be left child.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So if B is greater than
e, then e's right is B.
Otherwise, e's left is B, right?
Now, suppose comparisons
are expensive
and they don't want to do a
comparison to find this out.
I want to play with
the tree instead.
What do I do?
AUDIENCE: Can you see which
one A was before that?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: If A used
to be the right child,
now B is the right child.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I haven't changed the child
yet, so I can do that.
AUDIENCE: That's still a
comparison though, right?
PROFESSOR: But now I'm doing
a pointer comparison and not
a key comparison.
AUDIENCE: If e.r is A, then--
PROFESSOR: If e.right is A,
then it becomes B. Otherwise.
OK, this looks good.
So there's the issue
of temp variables
and assigning these
in the right order
so you don't have too many
temp variables and too
many lines of code, and the
Python code in the handout
takes care of that.
But this is the
logic that you want.
So if you have to
write it from scratch,
you don't have to memorize that.
Remember that you want
to get from here to here,
and do exactly the thought
process that we have here.
What if I want to do a
left rotation instead
of a right rotation?
AUDIENCE: You just have
to change the r's to l's.
PROFESSOR: Very good.
Copy, paste.
Swap l's and r's and we're done.
Why do we need rotations?
AUDIENCE: To rebalance stuff.
PROFESSOR: To rebalance stuff.
OK.
Why do we rebalance stuff?
AUDIENCE: Because you
don't want your code
to crash when you add nodes
that are sequentially larger,
and then you try to find
something, and then it crashes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Why would it crash?
AUDIENCE: Because
the recursion depth
is exceeded because
you're going down
the line trying
to find something,
and you go down too far.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So pretending we don't have
a recursion depth issue,
then it's going to be slow.
So you start from a nice AVL,
and if you don't rebalance,
you get to a BST that's
slow, slow, slow,
and then you'll fail our
tests and still get a 0.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: But if you just
had a carrot-like tree,
or if you added, for instance,
4, and then you added in 5,
and then you added in 3,
and then you added in 6,
and then you added in 2,
you'd just get a carrot.
So then I feel like AVL
wouldn't cover that case.
PROFESSOR: Let's do
them in sequence.
So what are we inserting?
So you said 4.
AUDIENCE: So you start with
4, and then you insert 5,
then you insert 3.
PROFESSOR: Let's see.
4, 3.
AUDIENCE: Then you insert
6, then you insert 2,
then you insert 7, and then 1.
AUDIENCE: You've
got to rotate that.
AUDIENCE: Well, the thing is--
PROFESSOR: Well, is this an AVL?
PROFESSOR: Well, it's balanced.
PROFESSOR: Is it?
AUDIENCE: No, it's not.
5 is unhappy.
AUDIENCE: That height
of the tree is only one
greater than the other height.
PROFESSOR: So the
height here is 1.
What's the height here?
There's nothing here, so
the height is minus 1.
AUDIENCE: I mean, but the
other side of the tree.
PROFESSOR: So if you're
looking at this guy,
things look balanced,
but in an AVL,
this has to hold for every node.
If there's one node where
the heights are unbalanced,
the whole thing is unbalanced.
Otherwise, the construction
that we did before
wouldn't make sense.
AUDIENCE: It's all [INAUDIBLE]
within the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So now that we're going to
look at rebalancing, which
is the magic behind
AVLs, we have
to make sure that after we
start with something that's
slightly imbalanced, when
we rotate things around,
we have to make sure that
everything gets balanced
at the end and happy, so that's
a good thing to keep in mind.
Good.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Is it
obvious that you can
put any number of
nodes in an AVL tree?
PROFESSOR: Point
any number of nodes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It's obvious that you can do
one node, or two nodes or three
nodes, but is it true that
for any number of nodes,
you can arrange
into an AVL tree?
Does that make sense?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So if you want to have
any number of nodes,
you call Insert, AVL Insert,
and then you'll get an AVL.
AUDIENCE: Right.
But what I'm trying
to say is, is it
possible to construct an
AVL tree out of 13 nodes?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Or 17 nodes?
AUDIENCE: Is there a limit for
where that property will not
fit?
AUDIENCE: Right.
Is there some set of nodes--
PROFESSOR: I like this question.
I like this question.
So what would be the
perfect binary search tree?
AUDIENCE: An element
of log N height.
PROFESSOR: An element
of log N height
and the complete tree, so
something that looks like this.
Where did we see
this thing before?
AUDIENCE: In the heap.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So a heap looks
exactly like this,
except the values inside don't
fulfill the BST requirement.
Otherwise, we'd know how
to build perfect BSTs.
It so happens that we don't.
But is this an AVL?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: That
example or in general?
PROFESSOR: Let's start
with that example.
Is this an AVL?
AUDIENCE: No.
The node just to the
left of the root--
PROFESSOR: This guy?
AUDIENCE: No.
That one's of height two,
so it has height one.
PROFESSOR: This is beautiful.
This is as good as it could get.
This is an optimal
binary search tree.
This is perfect.
It better match the
definition of AVL,
because otherwise, it would mean
AVL doesn't like perfect trees.
So the good news is
that any complete tree
is going to be an AVL
because everything
is perfectly balanced or
almost perfectly balanced.
The only thing that's not
complete is the last level.
So all the paths from the
roots to the last level
are either height log N
or height log N minus 1.
So wherever you do
the height comparison,
you're going to get
a difference of 1,
and we can keep
adding nodes to this.
This is how I'd build a BST
of as many nodes as we want.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
For the fixed heights, why
we try to minimize the nodes?
Wouldn't a better way to
build a more efficient tree
is to try to
minimize the height?
So instead of adding nodes
up, just fill in the tree?
PROFESSOR: Very good.
So you're thinking of how to
build an efficient tree, how
to build a good tree.
Here, I'm trying to
prove the property
about the maximum
height of a tree.
So here I'm playing
devil's advocate.
I'm thinking, what is
the worst case for AVLs?
How do I make AVLs look
as bad as possible?
That's why I started this way.
So usually, we're
the good guy coding,
but after you're
done coding and you
know how your algorithm runs, if
you want to have peace of mind
and go to sleep well and
get full points afterwards,
it sometimes helps to
think as devil's advocate.
How would I break
this algorithm?
What's the worst thing
that I could do to it?
And if you can find
something that breaks it,
well, you probably
know how to fix it.
If not, you can
sleep well at night
and know that your
algorithm is sound.
AUDIENCE: In that example
on the board, where we said
the height of the tree on
the left side was h minus 1,
and then the other
side had the h minus 2.
For that h minus 2
tree, every node in that
has to be h minus 2
height, every leaf.
Is that what we're saying?
Otherwise, it falls apart
because there would be one
that's--
PROFESSOR: So we're saying
that the root of this tree
has to be h minus 2.
And the way we do this
is we copy this guy over,
so this guy's lopsided, too.
So it's not every path to
the bottom, just one path.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So it could be an incomplete.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
In that case, is that balanced?
PROFESSOR: So this was an
AVL of height 2, right?
If I stick it here, it's still
going to be an AVL of height 2.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: This thing
will have height 2.
This thing will have height 3.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So it's not everything
on the same level,
necessarily, that needs
to be of the same height.
It's only the children.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So the two children, so two
nodes on the same level,
might have their heights differ
by one, but not more than one.
If they could differ
by more than one,
you could have a link list.
Because they differ by one,
then it's sort of sane.
It's almost balanced.
Good.
I like the questions.
It means you guys are thinking.
I really like it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If they differ by one.
So you have an
ideal tree up there,
and then you have the
worst case possible.
That wouldn't affect
performance at all, right,
if you have the worst case?
PROFESSOR: So what we know
what performance is we
have this guarantee.
It's at worst a
constant times log n.
This is constant times log n.
The constant happens to be 1.
This is a constant times log n.
The constant happens to be
something bigger than 1.
I think it's somewhere
between 2 and 3.
AUDIENCE: That just
varies by the constant.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And since we only care about
asymptotics in this class,
we're happy.
But we don't know
how to build this.
This is just something pretty
that we draw on a board,
but we don't have an algorithm
that efficiency builds
this out of a random series
of insertions and deletions.
I hope we don't.
Otherwise, I look bad.
What do I want to delete?
AUDIENCE: Instead
of a binary search
tree as the base
of the AVL, if you
wanted to have four
children per node,
would this change
that much except you'd
just have twice
as many variables?
PROFESSOR: That's a
good exam question.
So it turns out that
there's this tree called
a B tree, which has
1,000 or more nodes.
AUDIENCE: B tree?
Doesn't that stand for binary?
PROFESSOR: No.
It's B. Just B. That's
used for databases on disk.
So there, you want to make the
height as small as possible,
because every time you get a
node, you do a disk access,
and that's expensive.
But once you do a
disk access, the nodes
can be as big as you want.
You can read a few bytes off the
disk at roughly the same cost
as you can read a megabyte,
so you're better off
reading a megabyte.
I might be exaggerating a
bit, but for a few kilobytes,
that's true.
So B trees have
thousands of children,
and they keep them sorted.
It's sort of like that,
but the fan out is huge.
And it turns out
everything is still log n
as long as the number of
children you have is constant.
AUDIENCE: But for this
rotation thing, though.
PROFESSOR: Oh god, no.
We don't have to rotate.
It gets a lot more complicated.
We haven't gotten to
rebalancing yet, right?
Wait until you see how
rebalancing looks like
with two children,
and then imagine
trying to figure out the
cases for 1,000 children.
That's not sane.
In B trees, they
use something else
to make them balance
the right way.
And of course, they're
harder than this.
So let me try to get through
rebalancing somewhat quickly.
This is where I forget
what I need to do.
Rebalancing.
So suppose we call
Rebalance on this guy,
and we know that the nodes
here have heights k minus 1,
this is k minus 1
or k, and this is k,
and I want to call
Rebalance here.
Let's first figure out
if it's an AVL tree
or if there's something
wrong with it.
What's the height here?
AUDIENCE: k plus 1.
PROFESSOR: So no matter
what the height is here,
the height here
has to be k plus 1.
What's the height here?
AUDIENCE: k plus 2.
PROFESSOR: OK.
What else can you tell
me about this node?
If I call Check RI
on it, it's going
to crash because the
rep invariant for AVLs
does not hold here.
This child at the
top of this tree
will have height k minus 1.
This will have height k plus 1.
The difference is more than 1.
Not good.
So this is unhappy.
How do we fix the situation?
AUDIENCE: Rotate
left around k plus 1.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So it better be a rotation,
because we spent so much
figuring out how to rotate.
Let's see what happens
if we rotate this way,
and the way to
keep track of this
is I'm going to label my nodes.
B, A, left child of A
has height k minus 1.
This guy is k minus 1.
So what's the height of A now?
AUDIENCE: k.
Oh wait, that's not a node.
Just k minus 1 or k.
PROFESSOR: So this is a
tree of height k minus 1.
This is a height of
tree k minus 1 or k.
The height of this guy is?
AUDIENCE: k.
AUDIENCE: k plus 1.
PROFESSOR: Or k plus 1.
The height of this
guy is definitely k.
guys is k or k plus 1.
Is that an AVL?
Is it happy now?
So this is the easy kind of
rebalancing, one rotation
and you're done.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the difference between k
minus 1 and k minus 1 over k?
PROFESSOR: It's not
k minus 1 over k.
It's either k minus 1 or k.
Bad notation.
Thank you for the question.
You saved everyone
from confusion.
No, there's no
fractional heights.
Anything else?
Thank you.
That was good.
All right.
So this is easy, right?
This is the easy rotation.
Let's do the hard one now.
What's the height here?
AUDIENCE: k plus 1.
PROFESSOR: What's
the height here?
AUDIENCE: Plus 2.
PROFESSOR: AVL, not AVL?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: k minus
1 on the left child,
k plus 1 on the right child.
The difference is more than one.
Not an AVL.
How do we fix this?
AUDIENCE: Make a right
rotation [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Make a right
rotation on k first.
PROFESSOR: So make a
right rotation where?
AUDIENCE: On k
[INAUDIBLE] plus 1.
PROFESSOR: Let me
break this up so we
could see how that
would work out.
So these two are k
minus 1 and k minus 1,
and these nodes are
A, B, and C. So you're
saying do a right
rotation here, right?
Let's see what that gets us to.
So A is the same,
and then here I'm
going to have C instead of B,
and B. The right child of B
is the same as it was before.
The left child of
B is k minus 1.
Then the left child of
C is another k minus 1,
and this guy is k minus 1.
OK, what's the height at B now?
AUDIENCE: k.
PROFESSOR: OK.
What's the height here?
AUDIENCE: k plus 1.
PROFESSOR: And the height here?
AUDIENCE: k plus 2.
PROFESSOR: Is this an AVL?
So we're not done, but what's
the good news about this?
AUDIENCE: Now you can
rotate it left around C.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Exactly.
That is this, and we know
how to fix this in one step.
You said exactly
the right thing.
This is exactly what we do.
First, rotate here so
that we get to that,
and then we're in
the happy case.
So intuitively, the difference
between the happy case
and the harder case that's
going to be happy eventually
is where the heavy
path is, so where
you have the bigger height.
In this case, k
plus 2, k plus 1, k.
So the heavy path
is this thing here.
It's a straight line.
Because of that, we can
rotate here and then
redistribute the
weights uniformly.
In this case, the
heavy path is this.
It's a zigzag, so one
rotation won't fix it.
Instead, we do one
rotation here so
that we make the
weights be distributed
in a straight line, and
then one rotation here,
which makes
everything look good.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So that's
just a general pattern.
And you redistribute
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So the first thing
we do is say you're at a node
and you need to rebalance.
First thing, you
check the heights
and see if it's
already balanced.
If it's not balanced,
suppose your heavier node
is on the right.
Then you go and see if
the right child is heavier
or the left child is heavier.
So you see if the height
distribution is a straight line
or is exact, and then
you decide whether you're
going to do one rotation
or two rotations.
So this is all nice and
good except for one thing.
The heights keep
changing here, and we're
storing the heights
in each node.
So if we're doing
all this rotating
without updating the
heights, then we're
going to have something
that looks like an AVL
but doesn't keep track
of the heights anymore,
so eventually, we're going
to make bad decisions.
So we need to
update the heights.
Where do we update the heights?
You can look at
the code and cheat
or you can try to think and
tell me the answer, either way.
So this only does
rotates, right?
If rotates would be able
to update the heights,
everything would be good.
I wouldn't have to
worry about this.
Pretend I hadn't deleted
the original case here,
which I think was A, B,
C, and then some children.
What heights changed here?
When I did this rotation,
what heights changed?
AUDIENCE: B's height changed.
AUDIENCE: B, A, and
C is greater than B.
PROFESSOR: B and potentially
A. If I'm not sure,
then I'm going to try to
update the height anyway
to make sure that I
have the right height.
After I do this, I have
to update the height on B
and update the heights
on A. Is this correct?
AUDIENCE: And B.
PROFESSOR: And all the way up.
Let's assume that happens.
Does this look right?
AUDIENCE: Don't you also
have to update for C?
PROFESSOR: For c.
Did I change anything under c?
AUDIENCE: I think he's
talking about capital C.
PROFESSOR: Oh,
capital C. Yeah, OK.
So the children are the same.
They were a and b before,
they're a and b afterwards,
so I don't have to
worry about this guy.
The heights here
haven't changed,
so the height here
hasn't changed.
But you're thinking
of a problem,
and that is good because
there is a problem here.
AUDIENCE: What if there's a
subtree instead of small c?
PROFESSOR: A subtree
instead of small c?
OK, so yeah, this is a subtree.
After rotating, this
subtree moves over here.
AUDIENCE: Wait.
You have to update A
first, and then update B.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So the height starts
from the bottom.
The bottom height
zero, the next one
up, the next one
up, the next one up.
Keep that in mind.
Nothing changed below this guy,
nothing changed below this guy,
nothing changed here, so I
don't have to update these.
But when I compute the
height, update height
at the beginning of
the listing assumes
that the height of the
children is correct.
So when I compute the
height of my mode,
the height of the children
has to be updated.
So if I call Update
Height of B first,
I already know that
this might have changed,
so whatever answer
I get is bogus.
So this doesn't work
and I have to do this.
This is rotation.
That's rebalancing.
One more trick to rebalancing.
So we talked about rebalancing
the subtree at one node.
What's missing
from this picture?
AUDIENCE: So you check
it on all levels?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I made some changes here.
My tree might look happy
starting from here on,
but if I did an
insertion or a deletion,
heights changed all
the way up, so I
have to go all the way up and do
more rebalancings potentially.
And that's it.
These are AVLs.
Any other questions?
Did you guys get them?
Do they make more sense now?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Good.
You'll have to play with
them on the next Pset.
AUDIENCE: By "play,"
what do you mean?
PROFESSOR: Well, you're not
writing it from scratch.
You have to modify
existing code.
AUDIENCE: What are we
going to make it do?
PROFESSOR: So you'll have to
keep track of something other
than heights.
You'll have to keep
track of a new value.
AUDIENCE: Oh, like the
minimum or something?
PROFESSOR: Or something, yeah.